is
your advising yep
I did outside
I had to stay at home this morning for
children relations and I pulled out my
laptop and it was
great quality was
she's a little better because I could
have beverage in my living room
but it was quite high quality and I
noticed that a couple hundred people
were watching outside of this room you
know outside somewhere which is pretty
good for Friday morning
um streaming video streaming this is all
streaming but also it turns out that on
that site they have the archival versus
already sitting there oh right yeah
uh if you go mess around and all and so
I want to encourage everybody to send uh
pointers to these videos to your
students to your colleagues and all and
really spread the word around our first
assignments website could do a lot of
that but these are really super high
quality presentations and
um
getting word out about the topic and the
availability of these lectures I think
will have a nice impact all by itself in
addition to whatever we're doing now so
we'll make some announcements about when
they're actually kind of sitting there
in a nice format that they already
sitting here now on the weekend you
missed a talk you want to catch up
um okay let me uh keep me with my spirit
of not making along with introductions I
won't make a long-winded one just to say
that when I sort of envisioned the talks
this week uh mostly I started with
themes I wanted to have a talk on
Matrix concentration I want to have one
on optimization on streaming Etc so I
picked some topics and then I picked the
name of the person who I knew was an
expert and a really good lecture and I
want to hear their talk those are the
three criteria the next two speakers uh
it wasn't so much that it was more that
I've read their papers over the years
and I always learned something that was
interesting and fascinating and so I
just want to hear what they might have
to say about this topic I knew they'd
say something interesting
so with that setup uh out of here on
thanks
okay uh
thanks uh so one thing I found out is
that it's much easier to be here for 90
minutes than there so
hey
there is all the adrenaline that comes
when you lecture and so on so please
feel free to to ask questions make
comments step jokes whatever is the more
lively things are the the better off we
are
so this talk is indeed quite different
in more than one way from all the
wonderful lectures we've been hearing
during the week a so the subject that
I'm going to be presenting uh motivated
is I'll explain in a minute by I think a
very fundamental issue in
loudscape data analysis
but at the moment I have no good
algorithms to to tell you or anything so
it seems to me that what I'm trying to
describe is is the beginning of of some
research effort that eventually I hope
will have substantial impact on these
problems but at the moment we're still
creating the infrastructure so let me
start with the with the motivating
problem I don't know if you ever ask
yourself why it is that in almost any
application of mathematics and computer
science to the real world graphs play
such an important role but there are a
lot of different explanations but one
key point is that there are so many
things in the world around us that we're
interested in which are large
complicated systems that are really
underlined by pairwise interactions and
we want when we want to understand such
a thing then the graph is really the the
ideal thing so you know anything you you
name it it can be molecules interacting
in in biology it can be people doing
business together
anything electrons and photons and
anything that you want
this is a very ideal situation but of
course there are lots of real life
situations where the underlying
interaction is not spell wise there are
more things involved so if I want to go
back to two molecules in in biology
proteins very often or more often than
not come in complexes they really
interact in a bunch of them five seven
of the time even more and what do we do
normally well what's normally done is
that we take this set off I don't know
seven mutually interacting things and we
replace it by click
but that's a substitute it's an anzas
but they're not a very good one because
you're really missing much of of the
contents of the problem
so naturally if you if you're exposed to
enough modern combinatorics you'd say
yeah the right thing to do is is is a
pig to hypergraph Theory but
unfortunately happen Buffs are a much
less developed part of
computer topics I mean the questions are
wonderful but we simply know much much
less and so another possibility I mean
if you don't know what that is don't
worry you you'll find out is to say well
geometry tells us a different geometry
of topology suggests a different point
of view a from Anthropologist point of
view a graph is a one-dimensional
simplication complex again if you don't
know what that is don't worry you'll
you'll know by the end of these lectures
you know and so perhaps and that's a
possibility when we want to understand
interactions between many things
together we have to appeal to the theory
of higher dimensional simplication
complexes so my second part of of so
there are going to be two lectures the
one after lunch is is going to
concentrate on on higher dimensions in
the combinatorial theory of how
dimensional simplicial complexes but
having realized this I started thinking
about
essentially every each of the basic
combinatorial constructs that we use all
I mean all around us and since one of my
main themes in research is to to View
Community objects from from geometric
perspective a dimension is a very
natural thing to look at and when I
started looking at these things I
realized that essentially all these
things if you look at them properly are
one-dimensional
and and they tend to have very
interesting higher dimensional analog so
the case with the graphs versus higher
dimensional simplest conferences is just
one of many
and it seems to me that in order in the
same way that we are using combinatorics
in the analysis of large data again
left and right
when we want to start develop to develop
a theory or algorithms that deal with
with many sided interactions this is the
kind of combinatorics that we would need
so what I'm going to be talking about in
this lecture is about how dimensional
permutations
and essentially everything that new that
I'm telling you today is joint work with
my
student subluvia
okay
so how how is the permutation so now I
have to make good on my this General
comments that I made so how is the
permutation a one-dimensional object and
how should we think of higher
dimensional activities what what are
they and you know what would you like to
know Etc
so
of course implementation is something
that can be represented and can be
thought of very efficiently and in a
very fruitful way in in several ways in
fact one of the things that make them so
interesting and important are the facts
is the fact that they can be viewed from
different angles and and how to connect
these things but here's one one
possibility a permutation is also a
permutation matrix it's the same these
two things are synonyms so so I'm living
here very cleverly Gap a gap which where
I will feel in a second a permutation
is
okay so I want to say a permutation
Matrix let's let's spell it out is and
and by n and they
of zeros and months such that every line
contains
exactly
one
but that's that's how we think about
implementation it's it's just a zero one
Matrix every row contains a one exactly
one every column contains a one exactly
one and the line we have
we we call them two different names this
kind of lines we call rows this kind of
lines we call columns Okay so
let me say here a one-dimensional
permutation and it's obvious where you
want to go right so if I wanted
two-dimensional permutation
I'll do this
I want a three-dimensional permutation
same thing
so it's a definition you know is it
interesting is it fruitful let's let's
start and see but beforehand I mean what
kind of questions do we want to ask you
know what are the basic things we know a
lot about permutation right you can say
in some way that all finite group Theory
I mean this is in fact the way you know
the ancient people in group Theory
thought about is a permutation group but
they're really all around us so let's
start with with just perhaps the the
simplest things so the first question
about which I'll have
quite a bit to say and the second about
which I mostly have questions
how many
question two
what
do they typically
look like
so
I don't know if you know this but if you
don't then it's really something
worthwhile knowing we we understand
random permutations completely
I mean perfectly well and roughly
speaking a typical random permutation
has roughly one cycle of length a half
and then a quarter and and so on WE this
is understood perfectly so it makes
perfect sense and and this has been
studied a lot what to understand random
permutations and once we know what what
these are and we get some and we can
also ask this question but as I say
about this I have some something to tell
you about this I mostly have questions
so I think this is a fascinating area of
research about which at the moment we
know very little
okay so let's start and and you'll see
that in in most cases
you already get everything that's new
and exciting or much of it just and as
you go up from one to two Dimensions
sometimes there are phenomena or
conceivably perhaps we still don't know
completely new things when you go out
from two to three in topology such
things are well known that such
phenomena but but most of the the real
story will happen as much much of what
is going on here okay we will see and by
the way one one General comment I'm not
going to take you through any really
difficult and complicated proofs what
I'll try to do is when we get to to
interesting proofs along the way I'll
try to get you know pull out something
nice from the poof give you a taste of
it so you know best moments of so you
can enjoy and not have to work too diff
to help Okay so let's try to understand
what is what what is it what is a
two-dimensional permutation so the
definition is very clear
you have an N by n by n
box
each entry contains
zero and the oil one and now there are
three types of lines there is rows and
columns as we used to and there is what
we call with two as we discussed in
shafts that's another type of and you
can have that that's a question that
makes perfect sense you know how many of
these objects but then there is a very
simple observation that this is far
almost as far as possible for being a
new object I mean in fact this is an
object that mathematicians have studied
for hundreds of years if only you look
at this correctly why because there is a
different way of of describing this
object as by means of a topographical
map a topographical map means that I
take an N by n array I'm sitting here or
standing here and I'm looking up in the
shaft among above my head the sits a
unique one
and all right the height at which I see
it
so what do I get I get an array and then
by any array the entries are between one
and then and if you think about it for
two minutes you see that this condition
translates to the fact that every
integer K appears exactly once in every
row and every column so a Latin Square
that's the name of this
please don't hesitate if you have
anything to say
don't wait and just
say it so Latin square is an N by n
array
entries
in one to n
every k
once
in every
life
oh
and that's really an ancient an ancient
object I didn't really dive into the
history but but Euler had some very
important contributions and they said
all in all those time it wasn't a new
thing
great so if this is what I want
then let's look at the literature such a
classical object must have been studying
in fact people have have thought about
this problem
for many years
and there was a very nice surprise when
I started going over the literature
you know I was
you couldn't you know
when you have some few minutes time see
what happened I couldn't find it I
couldn't find so the reference there's a
problem what where what's
the best known result and there is a
wonderful combinatorics book which I
often use in teaching by Van linten
Wilson
so in my despair I opened that book and
lo and behold the the best result that I
could find is there
so you could access such a major problem
how come the only place you find it is
is in a textbook does that make sense so
you'll see in a minute how this happened
I mean if these two guys actually proved
it why didn't they publish in a very
highly regarded the math German and the
answer is
that this is actually a very simple
consequence of two deep results
but the derivation is is just a few
lines so presumably that was their
motivation so it's perhaps such a thing
you want to publish in a textbook and
not
so what's what's the answer
the answer is the 10 and the number of
and by and Latin scores
is this
this I must some drama
I must create right
it's my role as your Entertainer
let's say in a minute why this is blue
okay that's the answer we'll be back to
to this in a minute but coming from from
where I came
you know when I saw this I really got
the Shivers because
we all know right Sterling's formula
tells you what happens in one dimension
well I write it in a slightly
non-conventional way but
this is what you see so conjecture
in the dimension
this is the most obvious thing to
conjecture
okay so theorem this is with civil work
we're able to prove this
is an upper bone
and we have excuses why we can't prove
the law about so that's where we have a
proof and an excuse
or in other words there is a challenge
there that I think is extremely
interesting but we'll get to that okay
so first let me tell you about how van
engine Wilson proved the result it's
really a beautiful result which answers
really Accenture is all the problem
Okay so for this I have to take you to
to permanence okay so let me record
the notion of a permanent
so a permanent is is
you know a chip but actually
expensive version of the of the terminal
it's the same on the determinant without
the signs so a permanent dose of a
matrix a
is the Sun and by n so it's the sum of
all and other end permutations the
product I went from one to n a i biofile
in the terminal there is a sine of Pi
here here you don't have okay so I think
seems to me I'm not telling anything new
to anyone here this is a classical
object the computational complexity of
this has been a major challenge there
are approximation schemes this is a
wonderful subject in itself that we
don't want to to get into the the
computational aspects of the permanent
really fascinating still not everything
is understood but I don't want to get
into this but being such a
natural in one on the one hand and
mysterious object of it the on the other
hand it's really interesting to get at
least some estimates for this
and in fact
so there are two there are two major
theorems about about the permanence
which when put together give you the
violin twins so let me tell you with
this results are
and let me just so then I will describe
to you in in general terms I'll give you
some of the the interesting points from
my work with two on how this inequality
is put and this is motivated by
proof of of one of these things so no
bones in an upper bound so you have to
you have to assume something
so the the one result
the lower bound
is the van der Walden
conjecture this was this conjecture was
open for about 60 years
it was finally this is from the 20s this
is
early 80s I think but
yeah
okay so we're talking so we are talking
about the lower bounds
so we
let us denote let us say that a is
called a doubly stochastic
if all the entries
are non-negative the row sounds are one
and the column sums are one so for all I
sum over J of a i j is one and for all J
sum over I will for you into this one
so one thing to observe
is
that the phase double is stochastic
that's an easy thing
but let's even discuss this for a moment
if a so let us denote that the set of
all doubly stochastic and bio matrices
by or my girlfriend okay
so an easy fact but we'll discuss it for
a moment that if a is doubly stochastic
then it's permanent
is positive of course it's not negative
we're only summing non-negative terms
but in fact it's positive
okay and this is an easy consequence of
the marriage theorem
okay because for this I don't really
care what the numbers are I just care
about the support of a where it's
supposed where it's positive and where
it's zero
and what this says is you can find at
least one permutation for which all
these terms are but now there is a
simple correspondence which is one of
the things that makes this whole thing
interesting a you can create from The
Matrix you can associate with this a
bipartite graph the the this side is the
rows
this side is the columns and there is a
an edge here if the between I and J if
the aij entry is positive and actually
so what this is telling you is that if
if this graph comes from from W
stochastic Matrix then this graph is a
perfect matching so it's a very easy
consequence of the marriage theorem and
and
okay very good
this is almost like a planted you know
like magicians who plan somebody you ask
great question great question okay so
good hey so we will get get to this
there is a very important
and
I hope to get to this the book of
phenomen theorem
which is again not hard if you know the
marriage theorem you can prove it for
yourself very easily says that Omega n
is the convex hand
of permutation matrices
and for this again this follows quite
easily and then now there it comes
something very natural a Omega n then is
is just a polytope it's a compact set
the permanent
is a continuous function
it's positive on it so it takes a
minimum where is the minimum see if you
never saw this and you'll think about it
for five minutes I'm sure you'll come up
with with the right conjecture and this
is exactly what Vander Valen
asked is it true so the most natural
thing is to take the most symmetric
object namely The Matrix all of those
entries
are one over n
and this is indeed the the theorem
so it took us like six years or so again
a wonderful subject worthy of of the
lecture in itself but this is not what
we're doing though so
the upshot of this
is if a is doubly stochastic
then the permanent of a is at least the
permanent of permanent of of this Matrix
or all entries which is obviously in
factorial of a interview okay so this is
one fact that we that we need
that's in terms of lower bounds on the
permanent of matrices now we want an
upper bound
again we need something
a what what's what are you going to to
ask and what we're we're going to assume
so here
there was a conjecture
by means
which was proved
that didn't take so long I don't
remember the perhaps about 10 years this
is from the 70s Blackman's theorem and
now we're dealing just with zero one
matrices zero one matrices the permanent
is just a matter of of counting perfect
matching and let's say
so
that's a n by n be a zero one Matrix
a
L1 through RN
are the both sums so
the iPhone has exactly an a ones in it
and now we are seeking an upper bound so
the permanent of a
is at first the product of RI factorial
to the one over online
okay
so where is this coming from why should
we think that something of this sort
should be true because take a matrix
that is a block sum of let's say an a by
a block and then a b by B Block these
are ones everything else is zero and if
you check it you see that for such a
matrix this holds with equality
by the way a curious thing that I I
don't again
I'm really tempted in so many places
here to take a sidewalk but then we
won't
we won't do the main things that I
wanted to do today a one thing that I
keep coming back to and I still don't
have an answer there is something very
curious about this result
you know of course if I if I transpose
then the hours becomes the column sum so
the same thing holds with the column
sums and in general they don't give the
same bound
is there something that takes into
account both the row sums and the column
sums I don't know but if you have some
ideas about this let me know I I find
this very intriguing okay
good so we have these things what does
it have to do this is all very nice I
mean it seems like at the moment I
started telling you one story then I
shifted to tell you another story
hopefully nice stories but it's no no
not so clear perhaps how how the two are
even connected to each other but now let
me
tie these things together
so how so now given now that we know a
the
falikman gorgev
theorem in the bregman theorem how how
can we
get to here so
think again of
these three dimensional array
if you think about it when you take a
slice in this and all these things are
really very simple so I don't even take
time to to convince you that if you take
a slice in this
any in any direction I mean parallel to
to the axis planes then what you see is
is a permutation matrix it's very easy
to to check so let us try
sounds very naive but let's try to to
get an estimate for this layer by layer
so in the first time it's clear we have
n factorial you know if the bottom layer
there are n factorial choices so let's
see what happens let's say we let's
suppose that we've already covered
the first so these are n by n and we've
created already K layers
sure what you just said already
that's right
that's right behind but it will take
just two more seconds and we'll get to
the right thing so
how many choices do I have for the next
layer
so let's let's think about it
what I'm looking for
is a permutation Matrix an N by n in in
the usual sense of flow of the word
but which permutations are okay you I'm
allowed in the next layer to put a one
here
if and only if there is no
one below me right so in other words
what I do from this is I derive from
this The Matrix B which is n by n Alpha
zero and the IJ entry
is one if there is no
one below
if I've never used one in in any of the
my part my this partial shaft is still
completely free
and then how many choices do I have any
permutation inside B would do so the
number of choices
for my next step is exactly the
permanent of B
but you could say okay very good but but
you know it depends what choices you
made in the previously the at least
is it the slice that you're about to
construct
the next one what is possible for the
next area you already created K layers
and now you're going for the next one
so that's how many choices so there are
there at least two obvious objections
that that you can raise a one that's
fine but what do I know about this B
you know I could have laid here various
choices and this these different choices
would give me a different B
so that's one of the amazing things
about these two the the upper and the
lower bounds are on the permanent of
being that we can derive from these two
theorems are sufficiently close together
that eventually they will give us this
so they're pretty tight it's pretty
amazing but they're pretty tight
and secondly
you know you continue and continue but
perhaps at some point you'll get stuck
but it turns out I mean you can either
read it from this or again prove it by
and I'm mating this point for something
that will come later on a
you will not get stuck against against
the marriage theorem proves to you that
you will never
please
no no no no this
now I want to do both
yeah I'm doing both for the moment for
for two Dimensions higher Dimensions I
will as I said for the lower bound I
have only an excuse they don't have a
result but from now on it's really a
very simple thing so let's just say a
word about what happens a the bregman
theorem is is right there you know
exactly they're exactly in B every row
has exactly n minus K ones in it and you
plug it into but when you get an upper
bound and and for this you have to do a
little exercise this is a every row and
every column here has n minus K once in
it you divide by n minus Square you get
it permanent back multiplying this will
it's just a factor to the end that you
get it's all very simple you you plug it
in and it's really two lines and that's
exactly
the observation of funding Wilson
and voila okay
great so how am I doing this time
hey okay fine
okay so what do I want to
to do next perhaps let's do something
one more thing that's relatively
a
so I'll leave this to later the main
thing that I want to do
so what is coming up
the main thing that I want to do is I
want to explain to you how how we prove
this
a breakfast theorem
Batman's puff was a little mysterious
and again it's a fairly fundamental
thing so combinatorialists came back to
this and gave different proofs and
different interpretation in particular
two people who
who did a lot to for us to to understand
this uh Lex driver and
Krishnan and so what I'm going to
so actually what I'm honestly going to
do here is I'm going to show you in
almost full detail
that the krishnan's version of of this
book so I mean
exactly giving the credit there is is
difficult but for me the the moment we
understood
his version of the poof I mean this was
a moment of Revelation for us a
and and from there on we really
understood what we have to to do so what
I'll do is I'll give you what the
krishna's proof of Wegman's theorem
and I will explain that I will present
it in such a way that it's clear you
know what further work we had to do but
that that I will not do and what I want
to to to discuss next
a is is about this higher dimensional
analogs of this but Mario please
realize that Syria yes
be done this is exactly that's exactly
the the route we take exactly the route
we take yeah perfect this is precisely
what we do and I'll explain so I mean
these proofs existed in the literature
and you just had to find out which proof
really you know is is such that you can
really pull it to higher Dimension
that's true please
this is uh that's that's the proof no no
so I I don't think that you're talking I
may be surprised but I don't think we're
talking about there is a probabilistic a
very strong probabilistic ingredient in
these proofs which I'll present so I
think we're talking about the the same
proof okay but let's talk for a moment
uh let's talk for a moment about about
this and the lower Bell why is it or you
know what's missing in order to
to prove the the complementary
the trouble is
yeah please
please
so I see it's really how Ellen can be
overbounded by n over e to the N squared
and now I want to understand how I can
get the E Square yes it seems like you
are using bergman's theorem yes right
how do you do it yeah I mean I I don't
it's really it's really a simple
calculation I which I don't want to do I
mean but but all you need to do is is is
ask yourself what happens if all these
others are equal and you plug it in and
you use Sterling and that's it really
nothing more than that
it's it's really a two-line calculation
I I don't want to do this if you want we
can spend two minutes in a break and
I'll do it for you you know
they I I promise you no more than two
minutes even I will do this and so but I
don't want to to get into this but it's
really it's really an exercise it's not
anything beyond an exercise
and I suspect that not everyone in the
audience saw this right off but that's
it but it critically Falls from this
last observation that the this B Matrix
uh the permanent of that b Matrix is the
number of choices at the next right
right that's that's the critically and
and the small miracle that we have here
is that the lower and the upper bounds
for such matrices are so close
yeah that's that's for using the lower
bound okay
okay but I I don't know
dick certainly remembers there was a
kind of a Bible when I started doing
computer science which was Guardian
Johnson's book on their books you know
the younger ones it was such a thing you
opened in this paper written uh there
was this book that every computer
scientist had on his shelf or under his
pillow or whatever and and the whole
subject was new you know you can imagine
there was such a time and we were
discussing in the book The the
philosophy and the basic things and they
say why why would you want to read this
book when you work for some company they
gave you something you realize it's NP
Hub your boss doesn't know what MP hard
is what are you going to do and then
there is this little cartoon there of
the guy standing in front of his boss
there is a whole line of people behind
him and he says I can't do it but all
these clever people they can't do it
either so that's so that's the kind of
excuse that we have here so
really this this method of of getting
the lower Bound for for the number of
Latin squares that's based on on Van
nuvaden's theorem won't work for higher
Dimensions so please maybe a quick
answer to that question I mean are I
factorials with a 1 over ra has a one
over e built and if you just do a spell
yeah yeah
what e e to the N squared right
this is very rough
two minutes I promise no more okay good
uh so let's talk about the Wonder Woman
and now now here is my excuse to why we
can't so let's go to one dimension
higher and then I'll be able to also
tell you about yeah remember these
matrices by a
so my title now is that there is no
there is no van
theorem in higher Dimensions so even
before ah great this is
this is still Hill
so a
the point is
now let me start in fact from from this
perspective a you can you can now
many of these things you can put to
higher dimension in the same way that
there is a bistochastic matrix you can
speak about let's
stochastic
it's a n by n by an array non-negative
numbers every line sums to one in fact
people in in certain kinds of statistics
and and
algebraic statistics problems discuss
these things to Great depth not just
free but but in general
and it's again a polytop and you could
ask is there a theorem like this
is a theorem like this there it's true
that a Latin Square
so let's let's denote it by Omega three
of them a
if I want to be consistent with myself a
a
so it's true that each Latin Square
foreign
theorem holds but does it go the other
way around
so far from it so what we prove again
with two lawyer
the number of vertices
of this polytop
is at least
Ln to the three halves so it's
substantially larger
and presumably it's I mean you can't
hear right here that we know anything
bigger than three but perhaps that's
small is the truth
so we actually so how do we do this how
do we prove this theorem we prove this
theorem by exhibiting
other vertices of this of this follicle
which are not which are not Latin
squares so let me give you the one
you're absolutely right there of course
the complexity aspect of this is just
what you
said
so I'm describing to you now a try
stochastic array
a
h
okay
okay this is a Thai stochastic array
it's a three by three by three array
every line here adds to one in other
words each one of those is a by
stochastic Matrix and if you add them
all up you get the own ones Matrix
that's a way to to check it but I'm
claiming that this is a a vertex
of Omega 3
off of the the other three
try stochastic the political why because
let's suppose that we want to to express
this thing there is a little calculation
again which I will not do but you can
check for yourself in even less than two
minutes a
let's suppose that this is not a vertex
so it's a convex context combination of
two such objects a purple of two
distincts such of this and and so it's
very easy to convince yourself that so
you I want to express this as Lambda
times P plus one minus Lambda times Q
well p and Q are again title with
stochastic arrays if you think about it
for a second then the zeros and the ones
that appear here also have to appear in
p and Q There is no way around them and
and so every
every in in every place like this one is
going to be a little above one half and
one is going to be below one half so now
let me construct but but you see if this
is going a little above let's say in P
let's say in P this is this entry is a
little above one half then this has to
let's say plus Epsilon then this has to
be a minus Epsilon this is in p
and something like this in in queue but
in the same way I'm almost written the
proof then this has to be a minus
and and what I'm looking for is a
bicoloring of some graph here and this
graph contains an out cycle that's
that's basically so so a bit more
formally then create a graph whose
vertices are all the half entries here
two guys are adjacent if they reside in
the same row column or shaft
and this graph is not bipolotide that's
it so this basic very simply we do you
know much more complicated things but
but that's this basic logic is there
okay so now let me come back so see what
happens here let me come back so so
a very simple consequence
in fact this is not exactly what we do
but let's not worry about that the in
our examples there are just zeros in in
halves but that's not important the
concept you understand but in so so uh
when the woman fails in a really bad way
to go as you grow up in in dimension
a because you see a
one of the simplest consequences of of
the marriage theorem is if you have a
bypass regular bipartite graph then it
has a perfect matching
and a
so this example is not there but you see
the spirit there is a very simple
example of four by four by four
thing with with one half and zeros
everywhere
which doesn't contain so now I'm coming
to to uh whose support doesn't contain a
two-dimensional permutation
Okay so
this means that the analog the the
two-dimensional analog of this even
simple consequence of the marriage
theorem is no longer true
which means that if you want to get a
lower bound on the number of of the
dimensional permutation
then we don't have the technology
so in fact a very interesting challenge
would be it's always easier to to prove
a theorem that you know is true I'm not
I'm not laughing this is and sometimes
it's a very worthwhile undertaking I
think this is an example
so the challenge is can you prove a
lower this lower bound the two lower
bound on how many two-dimensional
permutations or Latin squares there are
in a way that at least has a chance to
to carry over to higher dimension I
don't know such a proof okay so I think
that's a very interesting Challenge and
perhaps not helplessly difficult because
I don't think that people worked on me
today how then it's considerable that
it's not too difficult so but I don't
know how to do this
okay good so now we we get into
the more serious stuff
and
so so here is what what I'm going to do
a
I'm going to describe to you
yeah
that's our Channel
so
this is what we're doing now okay and
then at the end I will explain to you
how I think by the end you'll understand
I'll tell you how you know what further
steps we had to do in order to to carry
this proof over so it's really a very
beautiful proof which
has a lot of
additional materials and ideas in it
it's really very very nice and and the
truth is it's it's really
people like this the wisdom of the crowd
there is this the cloud is pretty clever
to begin with but it includes people
like bregman and Schreiber and Prada
Krishna so it's a it's a good team to
work with but it's it's really
the combined the combined effort of many
people trying to to understand this so
this is what we are doing now we're
approving the Blackman's theorem
Allah
okay
so here is really so what we're going to
use and this is one of the main
contributions of uh of Radha Krishna
a
H it's strange I mean I'm very friendly
with him let's call him by first name
even though he's not here a
is the role of entropy so we are going
actually going so this refers to we're
going to use entropy in entropy the uses
of of entropy in combinatorics are a
wonderful subject in itself again
pioneered and pushed by many people Jeff
Khan was was a major contributor it's
really very beautiful let me give you
the simply the absolutely simplest
incarnation of this but in fact with the
hope that I'm not insulting anyone let
me take two minutes and just to review
basic things about the entropy Saturday
that we are all on the same page so
if let's say P1 for PN are more negative
and the sum
this one with h of P is minus the sum p
i
know pi and and we are also speaking
going to speak about if x and no no
problems of measurability or any stuff
like this because everything you have to
going to have a a finite range so if x
is a random variable then the PS are the
probabilities of of the different values
the text takes on so uh what's what is
import what is important about about
entropy there are a few very simple
things one
h of P
is less than or equal no gain equality
if and on the if uniform
and
the one important thing
one additional important factor that we
need is that if if a random variable X
is actually a vector
so there is always this intuition again
I hope I'm not insulting anyone by
telling such basic things that this is
the the information that you're getting
by sampling X and now you get this
information revealed in layers so in
this case you need also the notion of
conditional entropy which is just what
you think it is and and so h of X is the
information that you get by
seeing the first coordinate plus the
information that you get by saying the
second coordinate conditioned on on the
first one and so on and so forth so
there is that these are all very simple
things if you don't remember them or you
saw them once in the past history that's
these are all very easy effects very
fundamental but very easy effects how
does this even connect to computer so
here comes a really wonderful uh
simple idea I mean it's a kind of very
simple idea that when
in the right hands as biologists like to
say can really do Miracles though
with the right brain or whatever parts
of your body or using to do mathematics
so
here is here is there is a set Omega
nothing to do with it it's just a big
set that's very typical enumeration
right enumeration is there is some set
usually it's hard to to describe and we
are interested in the cardinality of
this we'd like to understand that that's
of course a very common challenging lots
of like certainly in combinations in so
it's called computer size even in
Practical things so what's the idea the
idea is let's create
a random variable that is
drawn uniformly from Omega Omega is a
fine it's a cloud but but finite
and then
it's completely a triviality that h of x
is precisely the log by the way my logs
are to base 2 or sometimes I'll use
not important as long as I'm always
using the same bass I'm not specifying
okay a
that's precisely it
which means so I mean it's an
embarrassing simple but but really
powerful idea that if I'm able to get
estimates for this I'm able to get
estimated on that
and that's the way we understand this
this proof of Blackman's a good way of
understanding
spoof so we have the Matrix a
Omega
so it's a zero one Matrix like like this
Omega is the set
because I'm going to use
foreign
Matrix is a choice of one element from
each one from each other they're all
ones okay so of course just to make
again sure that we're on the same page
the carbonality of this is exactly the
permanent of faith
so now can we do something like this
so we'd like to understand
we'd like to understand this number
which is the cardinality of this set
let's try this this strategy let's
define a random variable that takes
values
in
uniformly among the generals the
abundance of a let's see if we can work
out the the entropy of this one over
and this suggests something
this suggests that perhaps we work raw
Bible
okay so let's do it
foreign
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry it's a
good thing that you ask because just to
make sure
this is what we're doing we're proving
this here okay and this I'll do really
essentially in full detail I'm giving to
you now the poof you know it's
joint efforts of many but as presented
by by radhakrishna of this field this is
what we're doing now okay
and then I will explain that comes later
then I will explain how this whole
methodology can be extended to higher
damage
but there are going to be much more
sketchy just explain one basic idea okay
good so how how do we go about this so
we have this set of tools this is very
suggestive I'm going to think of so
again remember X is a randomly uniformly
chosen
generous diagonal for me
so I'm going to think of x
as a vector
where x i
says
who
was chosen or who
is X's
element one element
in the row I
okay
it's a
you know as always improves you
first run
and you crash into the wall this is soon
going to happen to us and then you sit
there and cry a little bit find ways
around it and so that's uh the first we
are now you know raise yourself we're
going to hit our nose soon but it will
pay a so okay h of x
Islam
give an X1
okay let's concentrate on this so what
do we know we are now dealing
we are now dealing with with row I and
we already know what the choices were so
remember X is is a uniformly chosen
generalized diagonal in a
let me
just a quick reminder
these are the two things that we need to
remember about about entropy okay
so what do things look like this is
here's the Matrix
this is row I so just for convenience
you remember I only have one assumption
about Torah it has RI ones in it so just
for convenience
I rearrange the columns so that they're
here and
okay and now
we already know what we have done
perhaps in this row we picked up this
guy
and there is
one special guy here
it's a
this is the one this blue guy is what x
chose
from from row I
so I already know what the choices were
in previous
and so on and so forth and now I come to
here so I want to use
this thing what can I say
about this term I can say about this
term that it's at most
log of n i where
and I so
given this information given that these
were the choices that X made in the
previous songs
and I they're
still some places for example this is
still potentially available there is
nothing selected beforehand so ni
is
the number
of let me call it
available
once
in real life
okay
so this means
this is remember this is log
of Permanente so the the quality that we
got is that log
of Permanente is less than or equal
sum over I
the expected value with respect to the
choice of X log of Ni
now it's the time that we hit our head
against the wall because what do we know
about this Sinai
it's a random variable
what do we know about its distribution
this is we have to do something
better we have to do something more
clever because this this doesn't bias
anything
so let me just introduce
a bit more of
and this is really where this really
brilliant idea comes in which
traces back to Brandman that has been
clarified over the years
so
let me let me give before before I do
this
a now let me just tell you right away
what we're going to do a
foreign
clever idea is to not
there is nothing sacred about this order
of the Rose
of course it affected very substantially
the calculation that we did but there is
nothing sacred about this so the new
idea is
let us
scan the rows
in a random ordering
Sigma
so we do these things we do we write
this this inequality
but with respect
to a random ordering of the of the road
so
so when I average this over the choices
of Sigma
what I get
is here it's a constant so the averaging
doesn't make any difference so again the
log
of permanent Affair is less than or
equal the sum over I
the effects
log of n i of of Sigma
this means now how many available ones
there are in the iso if I scan the rows
by the auto signal
yes
yes sure sure it's a random variable
it's a random variable so so this is why
I started the first attempt at okay we
failed what do we know about ni but this
randomization is going to help us do
this
station over there yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
absolutely right
both of them sorry you are absolutely
right yeah yeah sure
but even even beforehand let's just take
a look at this and see that we're here
getting information about or about the
log of the permanent so let's take the
log here and and see what we're aiming
so the statement is the same of course
is saying that log
of Permanente is less than or equal the
sum over I 1 over RI log of I factorial
let me write it as log of 1 plus log of
2.
so this is what we're expecting to
to be receiving okay
so let's now let's now look at this and
see if we can really convince ourselves
so the claim is that this is precisely
that this is equal
to
sum over I is the same thing exactly
this thing
this is what we're aiming it
now
no no but actually it's equal it would
be enough to show less than or equal to
that it's actually equal
so why
think about it now now this is a a
metaphor from running you have this
sure
actually that first
terms
this guy is equal to this one okay
what does it mean ni of Sigma is not
necessarily the iso it's the I show that
you visit when you have
precise
this is
the contribution
of row I so I keep the name the original
name
when scanned
when the rows are scanned in order Sigma
okay
this is what I meant yes please U.S
campus first and I would have been all
right if you have scanned it last year a
bit more that's right absolutely yeah
yeah good good good yeah yeah yeah this
for example yeah that's very good if I
happen to if Sigma puts I first then ni
equals r i if it puts it last then it's
necessarily one yeah that's that's a
good indication just to make sure that
we are thinking about the same thing but
here I'm I I want to use my my running
metaphor so you see in each of these
columns so you see where these guys are
are completely irrelevant for me they
they're really power out of the game
in this part of the Matrix they are
exactly RI things chosen Alli places
Chosen and
it's them with whom so think of it this
way we a so these these columns or the
these positions correspond to others you
have RI runners in a competition and
there is somebody let's say your friend
who you really care about
the offense position in in in the run
and what he's going to get because of
this expression with the log
is going to get
the score is going to be
log of one if
our friend
comes in last
it's going to be log of 2 if he's
pre-ordinate pre last and so on it's in
general it's log of T where
he is teeth
from the bottom
it doesn't matter where the zeros are no
no absolutely unimportant let me just
finish this so now what happens you have
you have
they come in in a different in in all
orders and so his position is uniformly
distributed among the places a
one-to-one which is exactly what you got
here
and the poof
it takes a moment to think but hey I I
find this poof really beautiful and I
can say this it's not my proof it's
everyone else is so okay
yes yes yes yes yes
right okay so what do we do so as I said
this is this uh
nothing to do with this I'm a user this
this is not our work but how do you do
this now in higher Dimension so let's
say so I'll just describe the first term
and then the first step it's
this is this is the most profound idea
what we did is is more technical not not
I mean it's quite challenging but but
the profound idea certainly comes from
there so what we do now
is so Ally is again so the expression
first of all becomes a bit more
ugly and and complicated and so on but
the concept Remains the Same so we there
is an expression that has to do with how
many ones so let's say I pick One
Direction let's say I stay with rose and
there is an inequality
more complicated than that which I don't
even want to to write out which looks
only at how many ones there there are
initial okay just close the same
asymmetry we we also carry it through
and now we pick an order so we we start
doing the same thing except now we scan
the rows layer by layer and then in each
layer the rows come in so we pick a
sorry we pick a random ordering of the
layers and we pick
and you pick a random modeling in each
layer of of the rows now
what is happening here what is happening
here that what I'm saying now is is
perfectly okay right but you have to do
some calculation to convince yourself
this is in fact something that you can
do even without calculation so if I want
to keep this metaphor of the running
competition
what happens is that here we are sending
our Runners to two competitions
so a you there is first day first
competition everyone that beat our
friend is is kicked out of the of the is
already you know I don't know what to do
with them but you do something to them
you send them elsewhere and then the
same group of remaining people you let
them run again and the score that that
our friend gets is the log of his
position in the second run
that's in two dimensions and so on and
so forth the same thing in in every
Dimension there is one more repetition
of this running game that's it so the
calculations become more painful and so
on but but you get what you wanted okay
so this is a
as much as I want to wanted to tell you
about this but now I I want to
it's at the beginning yeah I think I'm
doing quite okay with the with the time
so
for now on it's much more
stories and speculations and problems
and so on now we can really sit back and
relax like this was the this was a tough
part
but it's really when you start thinking
about this it really opens
an unbelievable array of questions there
and it's really rough
you know it's like an end of a climb you
now see
the whole new territory ahead of you and
so much to do
Okay so
let me explain
please
um so you do the entropy method still or
uh
same same thing same thing so the only
so let me explain again so what we do in
let's say just just in in a
let's say just to get the upper bound an
alternative uh pull for the upper Bound
for for the next Dimension so you take
the layers
it's a random model and within each
layer you go on the rows and and again
the score that you give yourself
eventually because is is the log of how
many
of the end of this how many available
ones there
right exactly exactly okay so this is
just
repeating this thing twice but so now I
want to explain this this big View and
and what is going on here
so remember at the beginning I said if I
want to count them I want to understand
what they look like when they're random
this I think is a huge Challenge and I
have very little profile let me tell you
the one or two things that we know about
this but uh
I I think this is really
a fascinating problem so the one result
that we have here
so the question
there are many questions of this type
but the one question let's say first
question of this thought that you may
may want to to to ask yourself is
what does a random
Justice Latin square look like
as I mentioned to you at the beginning
render permutation we understand very
well with the random permutation look
like looks like these things are
understood in fantastic detail
about this we know very little so
there is
a Markov chain
due to
passes
and Jacobson
a
which
so I don't know some people Alistair was
one of the
initial the first people who who study
these things a Markov chain rapidly
mixing micro changes main means of
counting you know enumeration
these so these people have constructed a
macro Channel explain to you the the
basic things
whose states are all the End by n Latin
squares and they can prove that their
their Markov chain is connected
but we don't know whether or not it's
it's rapidly mixing
what's the idea so this is in fact a
concept that has been around for a long
time I think much of the the
Insight was gained in in fact in trying
to get a approximate
algorithms for for computing the
permanent that if you want to do
something like this it's a good idea to
to work not just with the objects
themselves but we also with slight
perturbations of them so for example in
the permanent one important lessons that
people understand relatively early in
the game is that although you want to
enumerate perfect matchings it's a good
idea to also include in the game the
almost perfect merchants and take a
rapid mixing multiple chain which will
spend enough of its time on the on on
the perfect matchings and and then you
can do all the enumeration so here
uh this this slightly perturbed a
version of Latin squares is one where in
all places you have one entry from one
to n everywhere and every column behaves
except there is one entry that
is a little different where you write X
Plus y minus Z
and then every row that doesn't touch
this at every column that doesn't touch
it just contains each of the numbers
from one to n exactly once and in this
row
a z appears
twice
I mean if you count
how many X's there are how many y's and
this is you you subtract off
I'm a little off I think here I'm
inaccurate but it's it's roughly like
this I think I'm telling I'm a bit of
that's that's roughly the idea so they
created the Markov chain that
connects both
uh the the Latin squares and and these
slightly perturbed Marco chains and they
can prove it's connected but we don't
know so
so this is this is a I think a major
challenge to to understand what they
look like
and they
so
there are many other really fascinating
uh High dimensional objects here that
they suggest themselves so a
see for me at least one of the uh in the
next lecture after after the the break
after lunch break I'm going to speak a
lot about a random simulation
competencies which are the analogues of
random graphs and and for me I think one
of the
really
Most Fascinating moments in the history
of the theory of Phenom govs was when
people around 1980 so bolobus perhaps is
is the key figure there a
discovered how to
sample random regular graphs
a
which in hindsight is not not difficult
at all but this was really an important
moment for the field
and so what what are regular objects in
high dimension we understand what a
regular graph is what is a regular
object in higher Dimension here's here's
one again a classical thing just so what
is a regular graph every vertex has the
same number of Neighbors
so what would be a collection of triples
now we're talking about the collection
of triplets when can you call it regular
so one way is every Edge is covered the
same number of times let's say even once
in such a thing it's called the steinel
triple system
so it's a collection of triples
that covers
every pair
exactly once
so how is this related to to
how is this related let's say to Latin
screws and so on see a Latin score a
different way of of understanding what
the Latin square is is you can think of
a Latin square like this
the
these three coordinates it's a
collection of triples
like this so
let's say this is the x-axis this is the
y-axis and this is the z-axis so you
understand the
how such a triple represents one of the
ones in the these three-dimensional way
and what's the property the property is
exactly that every
edge here is covered exactly once
so a Latin square is is the analog of
this the the tripartite and the number
please
Mario
yes there is a first question for this
which is like what how do regular graphs
relate to permutations because you know
this is the higher Dimension right right
right to myself that actually
permutations have the Cycles right so
actually it's the two regular graphs
which is just a bunch of cycles and
that's yeah so the the point is
yeah so so
there is now a whole so let me just
point out a some of the things here hey
so you see the the analogy between
strinal triple systems and and and and
another scores you can also say that the
standard Tempo system is the Latin
Square
with a symmetry
where if you have a one if a i j k is
one then a j i k is one and so on there
are six such conditions
so it's an array with with an additional
symmetry and so for example
can you
generate
penaltable systems at random
so one more thing that
so when I did
they already feel the energy levels in
the yeah yeah he already exhausted and
I'll let you go in two minutes
this is what happens when you teach so
many years I always look at the students
and I try to discover the moment where
they had enough and
and then if I have something funny to
say I'll say this and if I don't I just
let them go
foreign
okay so so let me so uh Wilson
Richard Wilson in 74 conjectured
that the number of
older and steinant triple systems
is a
one plus little of one
and over e squared to the N squared over
six and this six and B6 are of course
related so again with suruluria
basically the same technology the the
details are completely different but the
basic concept and the basic approach
again we can prove an upper bound we
can't prove the corresponding lower
bound so a
that would be an interesting thing to
let me see
okay let me just say
one last thing again show please
this is the kind of I I don't know I
simply I I and and everyone else in this
long line of people we we know nothing
of the sword yeah exactly this is what
it says how you know it's poisson
distributed there there is
I mean we really underst this is a
question that is really uh by the way if
you if you never saw these things there
is a very nice description to these
things with spaghetti I have a bowl of
spaghetti or each time you pick two
three ends and you tie them and what you
get is a random permutation and the
structure of the spaghetti after this
I'm not talking about your hands that
are filled with tomato sauce
that's we really understand these things
very well but nothing as you go you know
and I really think so let me just add
one more thing and release I really
finish many people are interested
in you know what expenditures would be
in higher Dimension it's really a
fascinating question and I should say
that I think that many of the attempts
are going in in the wrong direction
because in one dimension we had this
miracle that expansion in in spectral
Gap were so closely connected to each
other I don't think that this phenomena
I think this phenomenon is the one they
missed a miracle a fantastic Miracle but
as you go up in dimension I think that
this is not the right approach and the
right approach should be it's very easy
to to
explain what expansion is also in in
higher Dimension and and the goal should
be that can you find things that expand
as well as a random regular let's say
two-dimensional simplicial complex
whatever that means but to that in order
to even get started on this we have to
understand
what this random regular objects look
like and at the moment our knowledge
there is is close to to zero so with
this I stop and I hope to see you after
lunch thanks
it's also okay yeah I know it's okay to
ask questions now if you still have the
energy
formula
no no no no no actually actually let me
just say that I I said many times that
it's quite miraculous that the law and
the upper bound are so tight that in
fact this one plus little of one is uh
quite a cheat because this means you
only know this thing up to exponential
in lit low of N squared which is so even
getting this this uh this these upper
and low bounce closer together is an
interesting challenge
all right let's solve that over lunch
and come back